strange loop hello
um i just want to say thank you for
sharing the saturday post lunch time
together it's my first strange loop and
i'm so grateful to be here
the organizers people and conversations
have been just like amazing thank you
i'm like super excited today to share
patterns and stories on how you might
improve your operational tooling
with around ci with traces
worked with and found the same
general patterns apply when building
operational tooling for scientists
traders
crisis responders and of course where i
spend my time today software developers
real quick i want to share two of my
favorite talks from yesterday richard
from stripe talked about generating code
with simple transformations to make code
more usable
melinda from aggie talked about message
cues with architecture trade-offs
to make your platform more resilient and
legible
like these talks
presented something you're already doing
like ci with a small wrinkle to make the
system better i want to share my
curiosity in exploring the space and
help you get like excited and intrigued
enough to explore your own distributed
systems
in a similar way with traces
i'm going to leave some takeaways and
tools and references to get started a
url
will be
in each slide and the slack channel is
also right over there it's pretty long
but if you're open to it just like raise
your hand and ask questions during the
talk and we can have a conversation
we'll probably explore something pretty
interesting together
we're going to talk about one of the
hardest challenges in distributed
systems today
what is your code in production doing
how is it doing that
and why is it doing that
the patterns we're going to explore on
improving your ci
tooling are going to be building a
common language
for infra clients and people
how to reason about complex
issues with humans in your tooling and
finally how to use context to understand
what changed
i'm frank by the way
my pronouns are he him
i've been at sac for about two years and
guided many of our internal teams on how
to instrument and improve observability
with traces to solve problems
one particular problem we'll explore in
depth is test flakiness on slack's
monolith
it came down
by magnitude over the last years
of course with many as with many complex
problems there's never one single cause
nor solution for flakiness as it has
many inputs
from software and people
it's a socio-technical problem that
takes time to understand an effort to
start solving
for engineers flakiness is extremely
frustrating and for service zone is hard
to concretely pinpoint by the end of
this talk you'll have the patterns that
we use to solve multiple layers of
flakiness in ci
first
how many of you have been on call
wow yep
like let's say you're on call and things
are not fine um you're like trying to
find a needle and a haystack of your
deployed code and infrared to do so in
the old world
you can add some logs or metrics
needle so to speak
and to be able to find those needles in
the haystack you need to
redeploy your haystack then wait for
that data to show up
what happens instead of inserting log
lines and metrics into your code you
could teach your tracing platform to
answer those questions about your
haystack
like hey historically what does hay look
like and what doesn't look like hay
if you look at code traces over time
with context you're able to see what
might have changed
like both changes and non-hay might be
indications of where needles and
therefore problems
lie
like i i'd like you to listen for
iterations of that haystack analogy
throughout the rest of this talk this
hierarchy of needs describes a model
that i use internally to inform how
observability drives understanding of
performance and resiliency bottlenecks
this learning helps us make bets on more
observability changes or changes in
workflows to help people do what they
really want to do
and again we use
observability to inform solving problems
in this space and the
agenda is generally we're going to talk
a little bit about our department and
some challenges
and sources of challenges in ci
um i'm going to hear a little bit about
how we got started
and how we implemented our first
cross-service trace
what we learned along the adoption
journey and finally where we are today
so first i'd love to spend a few minutes
talking about developer productivity and
business goals developer productivity is
about building tools and programs used
to get slack software to customers
quickly and with high quality it's been
a fun journey to be on as slack scales
i work with teams that have the
opportunity to make engineering at slack
simpler more pleasant and more
productive
both slack customer and code bases grew
quickly over the last six years
and this begs the question
how might we create better internal
tools for engineers to build
test and observe
deployed code
well there are challenges
as the great philosopher uncle ben from
spider-man once said
with great power comes great
responsibility
in the same way that it is exciting this
is shadow side to great growth in
customer and code bases
there's an increase in complexity
oftentimes with fuzzy service and team
boundaries
here's a simplified architecture diagram
of slack for desktop and mobile clients
going through multiple backends
slack evolved from a single web app
to a topology of many languages services
and clients that serve different needs
the core business logic lives in web app
and routes to other services like a
distributed cache called flannel a
distributed mysql service called the
tests search and discovery and many
others
oftentimes internal tools were built
quickly and scaled just enough for
slack's main monorepo web app
in 2019 when i joined our team was
already growing and at about six folk
today internal tools teams consist of 60
people
and hopefully this challenge resonates
with y'all services are reasonable
individually within team silos typically
using logs and metrics
for example the test team might create a
prometheus metric for errors with
different dimensions that are meaningful
for development
another team
might see this and create a circuit
breaker for error rate but misunderstand
the nuance
and then misuse this metric at the
course level without context
and finally
user experiences in ci is somewhat
unique when compared to traditional
distributed tracing use cases for things
like apis
ci workflows might span over
days or even weeks they go through
developer environments
commits and different asynchronous parts
of the infrastructure
so given this
how might we do better
in my previous role i helped build
products and teams to help companies
with their hardest problems by reading
about data pipelines and platforms
i found you can create massive business
results when people speak the same
language and reason about data using
that language
oftentimes one team's definition of
dimension x
might mean something completely
different between teams and especially
business groups
so
let's take a different approach
how might we create a common
infrastructure and language to increase
legibility and unplac
complexity across teams
how might we create an integrated
diagnosis and reasoning about complex
system interactions with people in slack
how might we evolve our observability
culture
how can we share this tooling with teams
that need it
and so this body of work
was a slow conspiracy sprinted on
between many teams and didn't happen
overnight i want to say a special thank
you to suman and ryan on the
observability team who founded that
thesis around slacktrace and to all the
folk who improved the ci ecosystem with
traces but first how do we come to this
approach
it is slow is the hardest problem to
debug in distributed systems
it is flaky is the most heard problem by
internal tooling teams
a tracing system doesn't tell me what's
slow or flake or more importantly why
it's an exercise oftentimes left to the
reader an in-depth exploration of slack
traces written by my mentor and
colleague suman and can be found in the
blog post linked
for the purposes of this talk
i'll share a sky-high view of the
motivation and this infrastructure
first we start with the span event
structure
such that we can create an event once
and then use it in multiple places
for example a function within web app
might create a single span event this
deep span event
will contain context for the rest of the
user request with both upstream and
dance room
context
we can now ingest these spans from
separate clients and are able to craft
views from the same data model by
processing it through kafka
users can access fans
through data warehouse through
using presta sql queries in real time
stores like honeycomb and
search
here's a simplified view of our ci
workflows for users and infrastructure
i'll use web app and end-to-end tests
for the purposes of illustration
web app is is where most engineers at
slack spend most of their development
time it ties together business logic
from each client and dependent services
the ci workflow probably looks familiar
a user
pushes
a
a local branch
to github
opens a pr
then presented with test results
the screenshots show dms from checkpoint
an internal ci cd platform
it drives and bridges user workflows
between github enterprise
aws services like s3 and kubernetes
jenkins console and qa environments
which are really beefy machines running
slack to execute and end tests you might
be asking what might go wrong
good question
when i joined in 2019 a lot of existing
ci logic was written by the cto and
early employees it was mostly untouched
for four years it mostly worked just
well enough
well why trace
to find causation today there's many
more downstream services from web app
and the cardinality for ci traces are
very different from other services like
web app
ci has lower volume so there's no need
for sampling
but higher criticality
ci requests go through critical
interconnected systems and a fault that
any system typically means users are
blocked so what does a fault look like
engineers hit retry on their tests and
are frustrated when anything on that hot
critical path fails
between
2017 and 2020 slack saw a 10 month over
month growth
in test execution count so multiple
doublings
many new services came up to support
various features in slack and this led
to a lot of systems being stretched to
their absolute limit
and so there's a lot of needles
in the ci haystack the user experience
was bad for a while
before a series of projects around
github load
circuit breaking on dependencies anomaly
detection and workflow changes we're
seeing a percent
pr flake rate at approximately fifty
percent
um that's pretty bad uh this macro
percent
this macro percent pr flake rate metric
you could think of as bubbling up
multiple commits and potentially
hundreds of test suites that run on
every pr
and for developers this really breaks
trust and tests and slows down velocity
observability through tracing played a
role in each of these projects
and tonight we're at approximately five
percent flake rate per pr
like about 10 10 x better at the
macrometric
both velocity and confidence have
increased in recent developer surveys
and unlike previous years flakiness
wasn't a top issue and every day
we're still learning how to understand
operate and evolve this very complex
system called slack
many business requirements services and
teams are constantly changing
especially compared to when most of our
ci infrastructure was first built early
on in my time here i saw an opportunity
to work with the observability team to
build a better set of tools to
understand and to change how
we looked at ci
let me show how we got there
i looked at my early slack history and
found my first conversation with sumana
mid-2019
this was a time
when we still went to the office on a
daily basis and we'd grab hipster coffee
with colleagues
i heard about suman's exploration and
building of slack trace and i understood
a similar problem data platforms very
well and reached out for a coffee
together i then spent an afternoon to
build a cheap prototype with a
hypothesis
that this type of tooling would become a
critical and compounding value add for
developers
an e like
an easy place to prototype was our
test runner affectionately called the
ibot
even during this pr and a couple of
simulated test runs i noticed get
checkout was slow for a portion of our
fleet
we had our first tracing wind that
afternoon it turns out a few instances
in the asg were not being updated
which was an easy fix once we identified
the needles in our haystack before i
move on like i needed to write code to
make this happen
i want to call out
that today we have a rich ecosystem of
tooling that didn't exist or were much
more premature when we started this work
during this year's strange loop workshop
steve flanders
shared how to get started on open
telemetry and i heard it was great
also if you have the chance stay around
for the next talk by jessica from
honeycomb
in the same room
if you visit the resources section in
the link you'll find links to
honeycomb's reference on open telemetry
collectors
and a sample go test collector from
raikel
from aws
so what's next um
like this is a few months later now um
this is a juicy incident
uh this is day two of a multi-day
multi-team incident full of cascading
failures
um on day one
we were scrambling with one-off hacks to
try and understand
what's happening
and get a few overloaded systems under
control
on the morning of day two i added a
simple cross-service trace and reused
the same instrumentation from our test
runner
very quickly with
honeycombs bubble up functionality
became very clear where the problems
were coming from
git lfs issues
popped up on a third of the qa
environment fleet and this was slowing
down the entire system
discovery was a simple query now tracing
platform on what doesn't look like
everything else
and within two hours
um
ci pipelines were flowing again and
engineers could do their work
over the next few months this led to the
first of many targeted investments for
ci tracing
here's a sample
of the shared dimensions we created for
users and developers in ci to make
queries in honeycomb legible and more
accessible
these dimensions were stubbed early in
our library and instrumented with a few
clients
since then various teams have extended
and reused these dimensions for their
use cases
and this graphic shows a very very high
level zoom out for individual traces and
what dimensions they might use in ci
in a single trace
example tests it might capture all the
data shown in the rightmost column you
can then track earlier related traces
for all the those shared dimensions
elsewhere
um
you could query to find like commit
related tests and build traces
to see if we're seeing build failures or
other test failures due to code issue on
master
like and like let's go back to the root
challenge developer frustration across
lac was increasing due to flaky test
runs over the last several years
flaky test runs was one of the top
reported issues in developer surveys
for a few quarters already
in 2020 by mid-2020 automation teams
across slack had a daily 30-minute
triage session to triage and focus on
the flakiest tests
automation team leads hesitated to
introduce any additional variants on how
we use cyprus and and testing framework
the belief
was that test flakiness was from the
test code itself
yet
there wasn't great progress
i typically work on the infrasight of
the world and felt strongly we could do
better with causation on grey failures
by instrumenting how we use the cypress
framework great failures are where the
system itself reports as healthy yet the
application in this case
tests and the test platform report a
failure or flake
after some negotiating and identifying
no verifiable decrease in performance or
resiliency we scoped a short experiment
we'd instrument the high level test
platform runtime for a month and capture
some variables
what could go wrong
well a lot went right
we discovered a few runtime variables
correlated very very strongly with the
higher flake rates in this graph
you can see compute hours spent on just
flaky tests
at peak we were running
roughly 90 hours
of very large very expensive machines on
tests that were discarded because the
results were flaky
and to build confidence and address
concerns at every merge and hypothesis
test we queued up revert pr at the same
time
we never reverted
so the other
challenge i mentioned earlier is like
fuzzy service boundaries especially came
to how
services operated for internal use like
dev or qa
a broken dependent service like search
or an upgrade in a vendor's checkout
library api might mean that tests will
start to flake for users in ci
while a full discussion of non-league
detection and circuit breakers is beyond
the scope of this talk i hope to share a
few screenshots
of how we're able to build the glue for
service and automation teams to have
discussions
in slack
with
links
to more detailed
observability
oh and before i forget in the coming
week i'll be posting to the slack
engineering blog on how we produced a
magnitude of change
in ci spend with a deeper look at
circuit breakers as one of those big
changes
but what we found was like by detecting
and bringing people together in a single
conversation we could triage
a lot better
by looking at the same things
and just just like in summary it's like
test suite owners may not be distributed
systems experts
and service teams may not be aware of
how internal customers use their
services in conjunction these missing
pieces
presented a working space for disjoint
teams to find causes for ci flakiness
and give an awareness when a test suite
or dependent service was failing
and so let me share a quick story about
another recent incident
in august 2021
at slack we use the incident command
system i'm sharing one of the conditions
actions and needs abbreviated can
messages from that incident the
condition screenshot from our incident
channel says it best
back-end unit and integration test
suites are failing at a high rate with
out-of-memory conditions on hosts
each of these back-end unit test suites
may run hundreds of tens of thousands of
tests
the day before our incident spun up we
actually saw memory tip over the
threshold
and cause our anomaly detection to start
noticing a higher flake rate kind of
like the straw that broke the camel's
back
during the incident we used test case
traces from back and test implemented
earlier to track down high memory
footprint jumps for test cases we were
able to see
a high increase at the p50 p95 and p99
down to the hour over the last few
months
and subject matter experts were able to
identify a few culprit experimental prs
that may have been the cause for those
jumps
and during the incident
there's always this holding pattern
after
someone makes a change
here's some screenshots from the long
thread
um and i'm just gonna like talk through
some of the juicier parts like folks ask
questions like you know did it work what
are the graphs show
and during this incident this was top of
mind for all of us and
so like testing changes are always hard
um arrow one how do we test this change
responders
with identities and names blurred for
privacy were able to revert the pr from
a few months earlier and within minutes
tests appear to be passing at a higher
rate
arrow two
another responder was able to reuse an
earlier query looking at memory usage
for test cases in honeycomb
arrow three
so like this data allowed us to look at
telemetry with context
the changes and breaks became apparent
when we took this type of approach
so
in summary
we significantly reduce ci customers
flake rates and irritation using a few
tools mostly centered around distributed
tracing
this also helped us change the curve of
ci
when compared to baseline growth
um
this like social technical change was
super fun to play with in the last few
years and i hope to hear from you
um specifically about how you solve
these type of challenges in your company
thank you all very much
and i'd love to open the floor for
questions
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you